number one she has to try and put in a
really great performance because MPS
want to see how she can stand up against
kirstama after all of these u-turns but
even despite that as you said there is
now a big battle over a fracking motion
that labor are putting onto the floor
today and there is talk about gray and
Brady indicating to the Prime Minister
that he is setting a higher threshold
for a potential confidence vote that she
should be protected from a confidence
vote for a year as a new prime minister
under the traditional rules you have to
have 15 percent of the Parliamentary
party that's 54 MPS right into the chair
of the back bench committee to say that
he wants a conflict on his vote let's
listen
house I shall have further such meetings
later today
when the penny
Pence for the prime minister
for crashing the economy she should have
come to this house to explain herself
and to apologize
millions of people will now be paying
hundreds of experiments on their
mortgages because of her mistakes but
now she's here can she tell us given the
absolute chaos her government has
created while the chancellor lost his
job which she kept hers
Mr Speaker I have been very clear that I
am
[Applause]
made mistakes but the right thing to do
in those circumstances is to make
changes which I've made and to get on
with the job and deliver for the British
people and Mr Speaker we've delivered
the energy price guarantee we've helped
people this winter and I will continue
to do that
Lawrence Robertson
thank you Mr Speaker does the Prime
Minister agree with me that local people
and local councils are best placed to
decide how many houses they need and
where those houses should go yeah and if
she does Will she end the top-down
approach to housing targets and reduce
or preferably remove the powers of the
planning inspector yeah prime minister
well my honorable friend is absolutely
right we will abolish the top-down
housing targets we want
Mr Speaker we want decisions about homes
about infrastructure driven by local
people not driven by Whitehall and
that's why we're setting up new locally
driven investment zones
[Applause]
a book is being written about the prime
minister's time in office
apparently it's going to be out by
Christmas is that the release date or
the title
well Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
I have been in office for just under two
months and I have delivered the energy
price guarantee
paying six thousand pound bills this
winter I've reversed the National
Insurance increase and I've also taken
steps and we will be taking steps to
crack down on the militant unions now
what what Mr Speaker I think Mr Speaker
that is more of a record of action than
the honorable gentleman in his two and a
half years in the job
[Applause]
Mr Speaker last week the Prime Minister
ignored every question put to her
instead she repeatedly criticized
Labor's plan for a six-month freeze on
energy bills this week the chancellor
made it her policy
she be held to account which is not in
charge
foreign
[Applause]
Mr Speaker our policy is to protect the
most vulnerable for two years
I had to take the decision because of
the economic situation to adjust our
policies
somebody who's prepared to front up I'm
prepared to take the tough decisions
unlike The Honorable gentleman who
hasn't done anything on businesses he's
done nothing to say or protect people
after one year he's got no plan
here's Thomas
Mr Speaker last week the Prime Minister
stood there and promised absolutely no
spending reductions they all cheered
this week the chancellor announced a new
wave of cuts what's the point of a prime
minister whose promises don't even last
a week
[Applause]
yeah and it will go up the year after
but of course we need to get value for
taxpayers money the labor party has
pledged hundreds of billions of spending
pledges none of which they've retracted
The Honorable gentleman needs to reflect
the economic reality in his policy
Mr Speaker those spending cuts are on
the table for one reason and one reason
only because they crashed the economy
working working people working people
are going to have to pay 500 quid more a
month on their mortgages and what's the
prime minister's response
to say she's sorry
what does she think people will think
and say that's all right I don't mind
Financial ruin at least she apologized
prime minister
I do think there has to be some
reflection of economic reality from the
party
[Applause]
interest rates are rising across the
world and the economic conditions have
worsened and we are being honest we're
leveling with the public unlike The
Honorable gentleman who simply won't do
it and what is the honorable gentleman
doing about the fact that workers train
workers are again going on strike the
fact is he refuses to condemn the
workers we are bringing forward policies
Mr Speaker we are bringing forward
policies that are going to make sure our
Railways are protected people going to
work are protected he backs the strikers
we back the Strivers
Mr Speaker she's asking me questions
because we're a government in Waiting
there's no exactly there's no getting
away from this millions of people are
facing horrendous mortgage repayments
and she's admitted it's her fault she
shouldn't have conducted an economic
experiment on the British public but
it's not just her they put her there
they're keeping her there why on Earth
would anyone trust the tourists with the
economy ever again
okay stop
well I noticed Mr Speaker he's not
actually objecting to a single economic
policy
Monday
he's refusing to condemn the strikers
we're on the side of working people
we're going to legislate to make sure we
keep our Railways open The Honorable
gentleman refuses to do anything
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the only mandate she's ever
had is from Members opposite yeah it was
a mandate built on fantasy economics and
it ended in disaster the country's got
nothing to show for it except the
destruction of the economy and the
implosion of the Tory party I've got the
list here 45p tax cut gone corporation
tax cut gone 20p tax cut gone two-year
energy freeze gone tax-free shopping
gone economic credibility God
and her supposed best friend the former
Chancellor he's gone as well they're all
gone so why is she still here
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I am a fighter and not a
quetter
I have acted in the National interest to
make sure that we have economic
stability order
I'm good to hear the Prime Minister I
suggest that all members need to hear
the answer prime minister
yeah yeah
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
I am a fighter
delivered on
price guarantee we have to be delivered
on the energy price guarantee we've
delivered on National Insurance we are
going to deliver to stop the militant
trade unions disrupting our Railways The
Honorable gentleman has no idea he has
no plan and he has no alternative
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
congratulate Lee centurion's rugby
league team on their recent promotion to
Super League bringing Millions to the
local economy and furthermore would he
also guarantee there are excellent
women's Euros team including Ella tune
from my constituency tilsley will
receive the number 10 reception that
they so deserve
prime minister well I joined I joined my
honorable friend in congratulating the
Lee centurions on their return to the
Super League I had the huge privilege of
meeting the lionesses last week a
fantastic team who won a major
tournament for us we will host the
Downing Street reception as soon as
their training program makes them
available
I look forward to rumbling invite as
well let's not come for the leader of
the SMP in Black
thank you Mr Speaker after 10 new terms
in two weeks
we're left with a prime minister in
office but not in power and families are
paying through the teeth for her
mistakes her latest broken promise has
put pensioners in the front line of Tory
cars so can the Prime Minister perhaps
turn to her Chancellor right now get
permission to make another U-turn and
commit to raising the state pension at
the rate of inflation
prime minister I honestly don't know
what the honorable gentleman is talking
about because hey
we have been clear in our Manifesto that
we will maintain the triple lock and I
am completely committed to it so is the
chancellor
[Applause]
he sings
the prime minister 's approval ratings
are collapsing with an answer like that
the worst calling result for any prime
minister in history she's just thrown 12
million pensioners under the Tony boss
[Applause]
I also want to hear Mr Blackford
Mr Speaker it's not just pensioners
feeling the pain in the last week alone
inflation has risen to a 40-year high
mortgage rates are at the highest level
since the financial crash and people's
energy bills are about to rise to more
than five thousand pounds can the Prime
Minister answer one simple question why
does she expect everyone else to pay the
price for her failure prime minister
I don't think the honorable gentleman
can take yes for an answer
being clear we are protecting the triple
and if the if the honorable gentleman is
concerned about the economy why does he
continue to advocate for separatism
[Applause]
chaos
thank you very much
over the last couple of years thousands
of homes have been proposed or built in
Birmingham Northfield constituency which
puts a huge strain on GP and dangerous
appointments what's my right on my
friend the Prime Minister agree with me
but more needs to be done in the
planning process to make sure that when
we have large-scale developments we have
more capacity in those vital Services
prime minister my honorable friend is
absolutely right when we build new
houses we need to make sure there are GP
surgeries
skulls infrastructure and that's why
we're introducing a new infrastructure
Levy to make sure more of the money from
developers goes on supporting local
communities Ed
Mr Speaker millions of family carers
have been forced to cut back on food and
Heating
one told carers UK my son is incontinent
we don't wash him in warm water several
times a day this will cause him to
physically decline
so how do we pay for the gas to heat the
water if we are currently at Max budget
for all people and carers are struggling
enough already in this cost of living
crisis Mr Speaker
so will the Prime Minister guarantee
that support for the vulnerable
including carers allowance Will Rise by
at least today's inflation rate of 10.1
percent
[Applause]
struggling it is difficult at the moment
that's why we put it in place the energy
price guarantee to make sure the typical
household isn't paying more than 2 500
pounds it's why we've supplied an extra
1200 pounds of support to the most
vulnerable and I can assure the right
honorable gentleman we will always
support the most vulnerable they will be
our priority
hey Jones thank you
yeah thank you Mr Speaker Bracken of
Radnor has a proud military footprint
not least the Cambrian Patrol exercise
which I visited last week it is
considered the Olympic gold medal in
infantry training attracting teams from
across the world to compete in a 60
kilometer March over two days in the
brecon beacons will the Prime Minister
join me in congratulating all those who
took part not least the team of Gurkha
soldiers from the Infantry battle School
in Brecken who took home a coveted gold
medal further cementing brecken's
special place in the UK Armed Forces
I joined my honorable friend in thanking
everybody of Brecken Barracks who
organizes the exercise cambian Patrol
each year it is a world-class training
exercise and I congratulate brecken's
Gurkha soldiers for their fantastic
achievement of a gold medal well done Dr
Philippa Whitford
thank you very much Mr Speaker it took
just five working days for the prime
minister to crush the pound damage
Pension funds and send people's mortgage
costs spirally her new Chancellor may
have reversed almost all of her policies
but the damage has been done and we now
face yet another round of Tory cuts and
austerity period so I'd last like to ask
the Prime Minister and those sitting
behind her why is she still at the
dispatch box and when will voters get
their say on this disastrous government
prime minister
we are facing very very difficult
Economic Times I took
[Applause]
two in the interests of economic
stability and what is important is we
work together including with the SMP to
get through this winter and grow the
economy there
for securing the passage of the Northern
Ireland protocol built through this
house without Amendment before the
summer recess can she confirm that it's
the government's intention that the bill
should remain unamended and in
particular that the European court of
justice should have no jurisdiction in
any part of the United Kingdom prime
minister stuff I am completely committed
to the Northern Ireland protocol bill it
deals with the very specific issues we
face in Northern Ireland the free-frow
of trade and also making sure that the
people of Northern Ireland are able to
benefit from being part of the United
Kingdom and I can tell my honorable
friend that any negotiations will
reflect the same position that is in the
protocol bill yeah Dave beg Hillier
Mr Speaker we understand that this
afternoon's vote on fracking is deemed a
confidence vote in the Prime Minister
can she give us any reason why her own
backbenchers or anyone in this country
can have confidence in her after her
policies of course chaos in the markets
and wrecked the economy
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we do face very difficult
Economic Times I have been honest about
the mistakes I've made but what I don't
apologize for is the fact that we have
helped households through this winter
through the energy price guarantee the
fact that we've reversed the National
Insurance Rise And the fact we are
taking action to get our Railways
running rather than being disrupted by
the militant trade unions she supports
Mr Speaker there's been a number of low
points recently including
the Republic of Ireland's football team
singing pro-ira songs in the changing
room we should never forget the
sacrifice of those who paid the price to
maintain the Peace during the troubles
closer to home recent events meant that
spending is going to be more constrained
than originally thought may I encourage
the prime minister to ensure that we
retain compassion in politics in these
decisions including maintaining the link
between
benefits and inflation will she do that
remember this stuff we are we are
compassionate conservatives we will
always
[Applause]
with the energy price guarantee we are
going to make sure the most vulnerable
are protected into year two and I'm sure
the chancellor has heard
my honorable friends
representations on the contents of the
medium-term fiscal plan Stuart Malcolm
McDonald thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
let the public at large I've supported
the government in terms of the actions
it has taken to support Ukraine not
least because of of what's at stake
there but right now in order to maintain
that support as the public deals with
Rising prices inflation mortgage costs
and much else Ukraine fatigue is a real
and present danger and I'm afraid to say
to the Prime Minister she is now an
active driver against that public
support that has so unified many of us
that has sought unified that has so
unified many of us to do what needs to
be done
time where
[Applause]
in a time where in a time where resolve
and support of Ukraine needs to be
stealed will she make sure that she
commits from the dispatch box that the
economic and Military and political
support won't be another casualty under
this prime minister
it was one of my first acts in office to
make sure the military support we give
to Ukraine is equal to the military
support we gave this year we must make
sure Ukraine win they can win they will
win and they must win
sticking by her words and giving
communities and filed the final say on
fracking but as always the devil is in
the detail can the Prime Minister assure
me that local consent will be measured
independently and transparently and
under no circumstances will fracking
companies be directly engaged in
assessing local consent and if people
unfiled say no that that view and that
decision will be respected and acted
upon by this government
my honorable friend I know this is
something he cares deeply about I can
ensure him that we will consult on the
robust system of local consent give
clear advice on seismic limits and
safety before any fracking takes place
and the consultation will consider all
of the relevant people the regional
Mayors the local authorities and
parishes as well as the concerns of
those directly affected and my right
honorable friend the business secretary
will be saying more about this later
today
thank you Mr Speaker privatization does
not work it doesn't work for our NHS we
have another Amber Alert in the NHS
Blood Service a service that this week's
Chancellor sold when he was Health
secretary and it doesn't work for our
Postal Service with Royal Mail group
taking 758 million pounds in profit last
year yet our Universal service
obligation is at risk workers pay
conditions and 10 000 jobs are at threat
will the Prime Minister continue to let
obscene amounts of profit be made while
services are cut and stamp prices rise
or will she launch an inquiry into the
gross mismanagement of Royal Mail prime
minister
what we need is an efficient Postal
Service that delivers four people across
this country that's what I'm focused on
not making ideological points
good Baker thank you
speaker when I was in business it was a
real privilege to employ very many
talented bright young people
I always found that when you believed in
somebody when you gave them the
opportunity they went on to thrive in
their career that's why tomorrow in
North Norfolk I'll be launching my new
scheme the 100 apprenticeship challenge
to drive a hundred new apprenticeships
all over a rural constituency would the
Prime Minister please thank not just my
DWP office and Juliet Nix has been
fantastic The District Council councils
the county councils and an awful lot of
stakeholders will work for over six
months to deliver this fantastic scheme
to drive growth and jobs for young
people across my constituency
[Applause]
I do want to thank Julia and her team
for the fantastic job they're doing and
also you as the local member of sorry my
writable friend is a local Member of
Parliament apprenticeships are a
fantastic way for people to learn and
gain experience and I'm proud that we've
created 5.1 million apprenticeships
since 2010. Smith
Mr Speaker
the prime minister's chief of staff is
in hot water after lobbying on behalf of
a Libyan warlord a big tobacco it turns
out he's also lobbied for PPE Giants
Sante global
Is it wise to have a lobbyist at the
center of Downing Street
prime minister
[Applause]
Mr Speaker all appointments in Downing
Street are properly checked through the
propriety and ethics process and that is
the way that we do it in a completely
impartial way Andrew
thank you Mr Speaker when my right
honorable friend was foreign secretary I
know that she was acutely aware of the
importance of British soft power acting
in our national interest will she
confirm today the promise we both made
in 2010 when this government first came
into office that she will not balance
the books on the backs of the poorest
people in the world
[Music]
well can I pay tribute to my right
honorable friend for the Fantastic work
he did as International Development
secretary and I am proud that we have
rebalanced our International Development
budget to focus more on humanitarian Aid
and more on women and girls and no doubt
more details will be set out in due
course
oh wait thank you Mr Speaker
the last Tory prime minister was forced
out after a series of dodgy dealings and
failing to take responsibility for any
of it so what's this prime minister
getting the boot for her plan crashed
the economy forcing fracking on
communities who don't want it or she do
the decent thing and go and call a
general election
[Applause]
I have taken responsibility and I have
made the right decision in the interest
of the country's economic stability
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker every single member
in this house will have constituents
waiting for treatment within the covid
backlog
the health secretary's priorities are
absolutely right including her B for
tackling the backlogs can the Prime
Minister reassure me that the government
is committed to the series of elective
hubs that we've promised including at
the Royal Hampshire County Hospital in
my Winchester constituency prime
minister
well the my right honorable friend the
health secretary has set out her plans
to deliver on dealing with the covered
backlog and she will continue to work on
that and make sure we deal with what was
a massive you know a massive pandemic a
massive pandemic creating a backlog we
will deal with it
since the mini budget thousands of my
constituents have been in mental anguish
and despair
I recognize that The Honorable lady has
faced a week of mental anguish and
despair herself
she has been had people angry with her
she's had people who have mocked her but
having had that experience what will she
now do to improve the health care the
mental health care for people in this
country so that the the the anguish that
they face in the coming months is
properly responded to and dealt with I
could say my right would befriend the
health sector has set out a very clear
plan of how we're going to deal with the
backlog created by covid how we're going
to make sure people get timely GP
appointments and how we're going to
improve on the services in our hospitals
including Mental Health Services
thank you Mr Speaker the government is
facing tough choices but people living
with dementia face unlimited care costs
and that is not a choice can my right
honor a friend assure me that she is
committed to social care reform to end
that worry and relieve pressure on the
NHS
prime minister yes we are committed to
social care reform we do need to deal
with those issues
let me see
you Mr Speaker
it's always better to see a prime
minister at her desk rather than
underneath it
and she could tell us
why next week this house will be
discussing legislation that will abolish
vital protections on pension payouts it
will abolish
our right to watch the Olympics free of
charge and Airline consumer laws how is
any of the retained law bill in the
British interest
Minister
well Mr Speaker I think we have yet
another example of somebody who doesn't
want to support the British Public's
decision to leave the European Union
isn't it isn't it quite I'm sorry isn't
it quite incredible Mr Speaker that six
years after people voted to leave the
European Union there are people who
object to taking EU law off our statute
books now I'm a Democrat I respect what
business people voted for I suggest yes
I suggest the right rockable lady does
the same
Legend Graham Mr Speaker 30 years ago
the Westminster foundation for democracy
was created out of the war in Bosnia so
that democracies could flourish in
Freedom and prosperity come with it
this evening in your rooms we celebrate
that anniversary by hearing directly
from our country representative in
Ukraine from the chair of the Taiwanese
Foreign Affairs committee and the leader
of the opposition in Uganda a good
example of the range of contacts that
this great cross-party body funded by
government is working with can I ask the
Prime Minister if she agrees that this
is a vital contribution by our
government and our people to democracy
around the world and will she encourage
members around the house to join us this
evening
prime minister well the Westminster
foundation for democracy does a
fantastic job and I think we know from
what has happened in Ukraine the
appalling War perpetrated by Vladimir
Putin just how precious democracy is and
how much we need to do to work with our
friends and allies to protect democracy
around the world and I do encourage
colleagues from all sides of the house
to attend the event tonight that no
complete business questions I'll let the
house clear